jean-paul de trois jours en france fin
mai le pap l'annoncé lui-même place
saint pierre
l'adoption faciliter une série de
mesures décidées au conseil des
ministres
cuba premier coup de feu à l'ambassade
du pérou où s'entassent toujours les
réfugiés là monsieur bonsoir et puis
bien sûr le dernier titre c'est la
demi-finale de la coupe des coupes de
football nantes contre valence ce soir à
nantes en direct sur antenne 2 à partir
de 20h25 une rencontre que les nantais
ne peuvent pas se permettre de manquer
car d'ores et déjà on sait que le match
retour en espagne sera très très
difficile
nous avertissons solennellement les
états unis que la moindre intervention
militaire contre l'iran aurait pour
conséquence l'exécution des otages
c'est par ce communiqué laconique que
les étudiants islamiques ont répondu
aujourd'hui aux sanctions et menaces
américaines un communiqué qui rappelle
de manière abrupte mais bien concrète
que l'enjeu de ces tractations qui n'en
finissent pas ce sont cinq ans diplomate
américain détenu dans leur ambassade
depuis le 4 novembre dernier ces otages
dont on dit régulièrement qu'ils sont
sur le point où qu'ils vont être
transférés vous allez les voir filmer le
jour de pâques par la télévision
iranienne mais attention ce document a
été réalisé sous le contrôle des
étudiants ce qui laisse une impression
ambiguë ce film a été ensuite vendu à la
chaîne de télévision américaine cbs qui
l'a projeté hier soir à 250 millions
d'américains edwards dans cette pièce de
l'ambassade américaine à téhéran
j'enseignais capucci trois représentants
du clergé et les otages l'occasion
depuis bien longtemps en tout cas de les
voir a priori en bonne santé et parfois
sans doute un peu crispé nerveux comme
ces deux femmes qui va en profiter pour
lancer un message poignant à leur mère
en disant tout simplement qu'elle ne
s'inquiète pas et ne se passe rien de
spécial ici ici et ici aussi pour ce
dimanche rien ne sera oublié en cette
fête un peu triste jusqu aux oeufs de
pâques
deuxième message d'un autre otage
je veux rentrer chez moi pour m'occuper
de mes enfants le témoignage de sa mère
qui viennent le voir aux états unis sur
son écran de télévision
il ne m'a pas semblé moralement déprimé
je le connais c'est mon enfance nous
aurions juste besoin d'un peu plus de
soleil et d'un peu d'air frais enfin le
sourire nerveux en ce dernier otage qui
monseigneur capucci apportait une lettre
de ses parents avec la réponse terrible
de cet homme c'est peut-être un ticket
de retour pour l'amérique
pour l'instant le président carter n'a
pas répondu aux menaces des étudiants
islamiques le gouvernement américain est
occupé à essayer de convaincre ses
alliés de boycotter à leur tour leurs
relations avec l'iran
une demande officielle a été faite ce
matin auprès de la communauté européenne
des démarches ont été engagées auprès de
tous les gouvernements européens à bonn
on parle de compréhension et d'une
attitude d'amis et de partenaires
vis-à-vis des etats-unis aux pays-bas
réaction à peu près similaire en
insistant sur le fait qu'une décision
doit être prise au niveau européen ce
qui pourrait être fait lors de la
prochaine réunion de lisbonne la semaine
prochaine enfin pas de réaction pour
l'instant du gouvernement français
dernier acte en date ce soir monsieur
cyrus vance le secrétaire d'état
américain aux affaires étrangères a
convoqué les ambassadeurs alliés des
etats unis à washington
le pape sera donc à paris le vendredi 30
mai c'est désormais officiel il a lui
même annoncé ce matin place saint pierre
devant vingt mille pèlerins au cours de
sa traditionnelle audience publique du
mercredi ce voyage d'un souverain
pontife en france et le premier depuis
peas est venu contraint et forcé sacré
napoléon empereur des français c'était
il ya cent soixante six ans philippe
je désire maintenant vous annoncer s'il
plaît à dieu que je me rendrai en france
pour une courte visite pastorale du
vendredi 30 mai dans l'après midi
lundi 2 juin en m'arrêtant sur un parc
voilà donc qui officialise cette visite
du pape à paris et sans doute dans une
ou deux villes de france
on parle de lisieux et du village d'ars
près de lyon à vrai dire le programme ne
sera connue que la semaine prochaine
ce qui est certain c'est que le
saint-père prononcera le 2 juin un
discours à l'unesco qui rencontrera
auparavant les 130 évêques français qui
célébrera une messe en plein air à paris
et qu'il gallo gras sans doute avec des
jeunes des handicapés des malades et des
immigrés après cette annonce le
président la république a fait savoir
qu'il se réjouissait de la venue de jean
paul ii en france les cardinaux
etchegaray et marty ont affirmé que le
pape venait comme le témoin de
l'évangile est aussi en serviteur de la
dignité de l'homme
on parle de l'église de france
on parle beaucoup de son passé mais à la
raison il ya une vie très intense en ce
moment de l'église de france et je
souhaite que le parquet puisse voir
cette vie de l'église
ce but qui avait problème dans l'église
de france
dites moi quelle est la société humaine
qui n'a pas de problème mais elle a des
problèmes mais la visite du parc que je
crois ce sera pour nous un moyen de
poser des problèmes mais aussi de
trouver une sorte de sécurité de ce que
le pape vienne en parler avec nous
quelles limites en france sera le
sixième voyage papal à travers le monde
j'aurai dans le coeur et dans l'esprit
après qu'il ait jean paul 2 les
aspirations de tous les habitants de la
chaire est noble nation française le
saint père a encore dit qu'il répondait
à l'invitation de l'archevêque de paris
du présidant la conférence épiscopale et
du président de la république
j'ai effectivement ce voyage de
jean-paul ii en france est intéressant à
double titre d'abord parce que le pape
vient s'informer et chercher à
comprendre une église dont il ne saisit
pas toujours bien les réactions et
d'autre part parce que le clergé
français a lui aussi des questions
posées à jean paul ii sur sa doctrine
le commentaire du père michel dubost je
crois que le pape vient en france pour
comprendre cette église qui est assez
différente de celle des autres pays
une relative baisse de la pratique
religieuse beaucoup de choses qui ont
beaucoup changé depuis 20 ans mais aussi
beaucoup de choses qui ont qui on est
qu'ils sont nés par exemple 130 mille
personnes adultes font le catéchisme
chaque semaine aux enfants c'est quelque
chose d'important et assez original je
crois que le pape veut connaître cela et
qu'est ce que l'église de france peut
attendre la visite du pape
je crois que d'abord beaucoup de gens
pauvres la plupart vont trouver là des
fiertés d'être chrétien et ceci est bon
je crois aussi que malgré les
difficultés il faudra faire attention
par exemple à respecter nos frères
protestants ou a respecté à l'intérieur
de l'église catholique des gens qui sont
qui ont des sensibilités différentes qui
n'aime pas forcément voir venir le pas
mais je crois que petit à petit tout le
monde découvrira qu'il est là pour
renforcer la foi de tous les chrétiens
que c'est son rôle propre et qu'il le
fera
et c'est l'église de france je suis sûr
trouvera là l'occasion de se réunir et
de faire une fête ensemble
oui antenne 2 retransmettra en direct
les principaux moments de la visite de
jean paul ii en france et près pas même
en ce moment même des émissions
spéciales à l'occasion de cette visite
les codes obligatoire en ville pour une
période de six mois encore au moins
c'est ce qu'a annoncé cet après midi au
sénat le ministre des transports
monsieur le theule qui estime qu'aucune
statistique ne peut encore permettre de
dire si oui ou non cette mesure doit
être rapporté ou définitivement établie
monsieur le theule devant les sénateurs
cet après-midi les feux de croisement
sont l'une des composantes de la
sécurité ce n'est que l'une des
composantes il n'y a pas que cela
mais c'est néanmoins l'une des
composantes travail et aux progrès de la
sécurité routière est un impératif et je
vous rappelle les chiffes près de 12000
500 morts plusieurs centaines de
milliers de blessés
l'an passé voilà pourquoi le
gouvernement n'est pas disposé à revenir
sur les mesures prises aient décidé au
contraire à poursuivre l'expérience
est-ce de l'entêtement non plus
simplement c'est la volonté d'inciter
nos compatriotes au maximum de
disciplines afin de limiter les
conséquences de ce drame national que
sont les accidents de la route
affaire de breuil nouvel élément à
verser au dossier aujourd'hui le
ministre de l'intérieur affirme sur
l'honneur que ni le ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque monsieur
poniatowski ni les plus aux instances
policières dont était au courant des
menaces qui pesait sur monsieur de
breuil comme l'a révélé le canard
enchaîné monsieur poniatowski avait
lui-même hier déclaré qu'il n'avait
jamais été alertés de ces menaces
monsieur bonnet répondait cet après midi
à l'assemblée à une question de monsieur
émané lui député sociale
retient pas de porter quelques
appréciations que ce soit sur la suite
de l' affaire puisqu'elle relève du
secret de l'instruction
j'ai par contre le devoir afin de lever
toute ambiguïté de préciser que les deux
notes n'ayant été transmises ni à
l'autorité administrative ni à
l'autorité judiciaire
la première ne saurait être accusée
d'avoir caché quelque chose à la seconde
monsieur jean ducret a pris ses
responsabilités
je lui garde ma confiance
que celui qui ne s'est jamais trompé
jette la première pierre monsieur le
député
après lui après lui après lui
j'atteste avec gravité et sur mon
honneur que ni le préfet de police ni le
directeur central de la police
judiciaire
ni le directeur général de la police
nationale ni le cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur d'alors
ni le ministre lui même
non tu eu connaissance de ces deux notes
et que les insinuations avancé à ce
propos sont totalement dépourvues de
fondement nouvel attentat cette nuit à
toulouse ont revendiqué par le groupe
action directe contre une autre société
d'informatique c2i honeywell bull cet
attentat ressemble en plusieurs points à
celui perpétré dimanche matin contre
philips informatique à toulouse toujours
samedi les policiers ne sont pas
convaincus que ce dernier attentat
soient bien l'oeuvre du groupe action
directe
enfin la société philips dément que son
agence de toulouse et eu à traiter des
documents secrets pour le compte de la
défense nationale à 12 dec comme le dit
comme l'affirment plutôt le groupe
action directe 320000 veuve de moins de
55 ans et levant ou ayant élevé des
enfants et n'ayant pas de ressources
suffisantes sont intéressés par le
projet de loi adopté ce matin au conseil
des ministres à partir de la date du
décès de leur mari elles pourront
toucher une rente de 1500 francs par
mois la première année 1000 francs par
mois la deuxième année 750 francs par
mois
la troisième année ce projet de loi s'il
est voté au cours de la session de
printemps pourrait prendre effet au 1er
janvier prochain 1er janvier 1980 son
financement serait assuré par l'ensemble
des salariés les sommes étant géré par
la caisse vieillesse
l'autre décision prise en conseil ce
matin concerne l'adoption faciliter et
accélérer l'établissement des dossiers
c'est le but de ces mesures par exemple
les examens de la situation des enfants
adoptables seront renouvelés plus
fréquemment par les autorités qui s'en
occupent cela dit le problème en france
reste et qu'il y a plus d'offre que de
demande si je peux employer cette
expression est que tous les enfants qui
ne vivent pas dans leurs familles ne
sont pas forcément adoptables
une enquête de jean-jacques du fou d'un
côté des enfants sans famille de l'autre
des familles sans enfant ainsi entre le
drame de l'abandon et la joie de
l'adoption les problèmes sont multiples
abandonné bébé sous le sceau du secret
isabelle moisan 27 ans mariée et mère de
famille n'arrive toujours pas à admettre
qu'il lui faudra vivre sans connaître
ses origines
je ne sais pas comment vous expliquer
mais j'y pense très souvent cette mère
et je demande c'est de l'avoir jamais vu
pas savoir comment elle est un
traumatisme parmi d'autres puisque on
recense aujourd'hui environ 500 mille
enfants confiés aux direction
départementale de l'action sanitaire et
sociale pour détresse morale
parmi eux il y à 25 mille enfants
adoptables parce que vraiment abandonné
un chiffre en nette diminution par
rapport aux années précédentes grâce aux
aides apportées aux mères seules au
développement de la contraception et à
la libéralisation de l'avortement
seulement dans le même temps les
demandes d'adoption n'ont cessé de
croître chaque année 40 mille couples
attendent et les derniers chiffres
connus font état de seulement 7000
demandes satisfait une situation souvent
pathétique pour des femmes qui n'ont pas
d'autre possibilité d'être mère pour la
ville de paris actuellement nous avons
sans ses enfants qui sont en cours de
l'examen médico psychologique en vue
d'une adoption et nous avons 344 dossier
d'adoptants en cours d'instruction
cette pénurie d'enfants adoptables a
aussi des aspects positifs puisque un
certain nombre de bébés de couleur ou
handicapées
sont maintenant acceptées par des
parents qui autrefois aurait exigé un
enfant évidemment en pleine forme et
blond aux yeux bleus un progrès qui
n'apporte pas de solutions à
l'inadéquation entre l'offre et la
demande comme l'expliquent madame claret
qui depuis 30 ans accueillent les
candidats parisiens à l'adoption et qui
se demande bien comment faire face ont
adopté des enfants considérés comme
difficilement adoptables et ses prêts
ils sont difficilement adoptables
ils ont souvent des problèmes médicaux
importants les problèmes cardiaques et
rénaux orthopédiques des problèmes de
débilité légère vous voyez des problèmes
de comportement aussi qu'ils sont les
problèmes les plus difficiles à régler
peut-être incité les adoptants à prendre
les enfants un peu plus grands
bien qu'il y ait là seuil aussi qu'il
soit difficile à franchir quelques fois
c'est une très grande des presses d'être
cette quête d'un enfant les parents
c'est une très très grande détresse nous
vient danser toujours de très bons gras
mais très grand chagrin car tous n'ont
pas la chance de la famille signargues
ou qui a réussi à adopter cinq enfants
dont un handicapé
bien souvent la détresse dont pas madame
claret conduit des couples a accepté
toutes les conditions même celle de
l'illégalité et du trafic pour enfin
avoir un enfant
la cgt réclame 30 % d'augmentation des
allocations familiales la cgt considère
que cette mesure constituerait dans
l'immédiat simplement un rattrapage de
la perte du pouvoir d'achat le métro
parisien restera salle les négociations
ont échoué cet après midi c'est le
troisième échec depuis le début des
discussions
hier le parti socialiste nous vous en
avons parlé publier un bilan de ses
rapports avec les communistes dans les
municipalités d'union de la gauche en
france le dernier exemple en date des
difficultés qui existent entre les deux
partenaires au niveau local et celui de
brest qui a abouti dimanche à la
réélection du maire socialiste monsieur
le blé qui ne considère pas pour autant
que cette péripétie remet en cause la
politique d'union du parti socialiste
que pensent les électeurs et les
habitants de brest de ces querelles
patricia charles haley est allé le leur
demande
hier après midi mardi à la sortie de
l'arsenal c'est la plus grosse
entreprise de la ville et nous pensons
trouver là les premiers échos les
premières réactions à la violente crise
municipale du week end
ils sont rangés pas pour la bonne raison
que c'était un peu de l'incompatibilité
d'humeur potable et s'arrange contre
quoi pourquoi à votre avis
on vous savez madame les gens ne
s'intéressent pas beaucoup
ce qui a été élu dimanche dernier une
enseignante m'intéresse pas les brestois
semblent moins ému connais la classe
politique par les difficultés de l'union
de la gauche dans leur ville
le journal régional n'est accordée
prière que quelques lignes il est vrai
que la population est habituée aux
escarmouches entre socialistes et
communistes
elle pense aussi que cette querelle ne
résoudra pas sont plus graves problèmes
le chômage
il y a dix mille demandeurs d'emploi à
brest
les travailleurs brestois font une
expérience une expérience qui met en
évidence la nocivité du rôle qui parti
socialiste lorsqu'il est placé en
position de majoritaire et dominateur et
que cette expérience sera utile car en
se rassemblant autour des élus
communistes de leur parti bien l'union
on trouvera des bases plus solides pour
aller de l'avant vers le progrès social
pour plus de démocratie
je pense pour le maire l'action commune
y est une décision nationale dictée je
ne peux pas vous rapporter la preuve par
neuf
mais certainement assuré qu'ils aient
trouvé un point faible pour
l'application d'une politique du général
qui consiste à attaquer quand tuellement
le parti socialiste c'est vraisemblable
mais le budget en lui-même ne peut pas
être un argument seul pour justifier
cette rupture
on croyait encore en ligne en indochine
je crois au bilan de la gauche est une
nécessité
en tout cas l'équipe municipale ne peut
plus compter sur l'intérêt provoquée par
son élection il y a trois ans plus grave
les jeunes aujourd'hui ont bien du mal à
se reconnaître dans ces conflits
oh je me retrouve pas je pense que notre
époux étaient cantonaux football but je
suis notre en tout
vous n'allez pas dire que j'en ai trouvé
ma tribu tout à fait l'autre but la
politique ou d'un tel enfer du tout
que peut-il se passer alors à bresse
chacun campe sur ses positions de plus
en plus ferme
l'équipe municipale aura bien des
difficultés à aller au bout de son
mandat
surtout si sa bataille se transforme en
querelles nationales
étrangers en bref à washington président
sadate continue ses entretiens avec
monsieur carter pour essayer d'aboutir à
un accord sur l'autonomie palestinienne
dans les territoires occupés les
positions entre l'egypte et israël reste
toujours très éloignées jeu carter a
évoqué hier soir ce qui représente
toujours pour lui les éléments de base
un accord à savoir la complète autonomie
des palestiniens et le retrait total des
ide règne monsieur begin
le premier ministre israélien doit venir
la semaine prochaine à washington
ocha de difficile cessez le feu négocié
par le chef de l'état togolais et par le
secrétaire général de l'onu à
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
n'aura duré que quelques heures à peine
les combats ont repris ce matin avec
violence des milliers de cubains sont
toujours réfugiées dans les jardins de
l'ambassade du pérou à la havane ces
candidats à l'émigration dont nous
n'avons toujours pas malheureusement
d'image à vous montrer sont maintenant
en butte à des contre manifestations
d'étudiants et des colliers partisans du
président castro pour l'instant la seule
réaction officielle du gouvernement
cubain consiste à affirmer que la
majorité des réfugiés est composé de
délinquants je cite le gouvernement de
délinquants de vagabonds et
d'homosexuels dernier événement en date
ce soir un chauffeur de taxi ce qu
indique une dépêche de l'agencé france
presse
un chauffeur de taxi a essuyé des coups
de feu de la police cubaine alors qu'ils
tentaient de forcer un barrage pour se
rendre avec son véhicule à l'intérieur
des jardins de l'ambassade du pérou et
puis aux etats unis cette fois ci c'est
un américain qui a détourné un avion
dans lequel il n'y a pas de passagers à
l'intérieur un avion en direction de
cuba où il demande à être conduit en
belgique le gouvernement de monsieur
martens a officiellement démissionné
aujourd'hui cette démission illustre
l'incapacité actuelle les autorités
politiques belges de s'entendre sur un
statut de bruxelles et de sa région
enfin le dollar a chuté aujourd'hui et
l'or a monté sur toutes les grandes
places financières à paris d' amener
américaine a été coté 4 francs 37 contre
454 il ya encore la preuve que les
boursiers ne sont pas impressionnés et
craignent plutôt même les conséquences
des mesures du président carter dans la
sphère iranienne et puis une dépêche
tomber juste avant de ce journal lundi
que l'union soviétique a lancé ce soir
un nouveau vaisseau cosmique habité et
piloté par un lieutenant colonel qui
doit aller rejoindre
train de l'espace qui est déjà engagée
par les soviétiques
les pronostics de pirey de bresse pour
le tiercé de demain pour terminer dans
le prix étant pas vincennes vous allez
voir sur votre écran
les pronostics de pierre de bresse je
vous laisse le soin de noter les numéros
et puis on amène une dépêche que je vous
donnais avant la météo qui est
importante vous savez qu'on attendait
après l'attentât perpétré contre une
crèche en territoire israélien par des
apps par des palestiniens on attendait
une réaction des israéliens et bien on
apprend ce soir que le porte parole de
l'armée israélienne confirme la présence
d'éléments armés israéliens au sud liban
qui ont pénétré au delà ce sont les
propres termes de ce conseiller de
presse pénétrer au delà de la frontière
pour établir des positions de défense
avancée l'établissement de ses positions
est destiné selon ce porte parole à
empêcher le renouvellement d'éventuelles
attaques de commando palestinien
cette information a bien sûr des
développements que nous voudrons dans
notre dernier journal voilà dalons nous
quitter pour rejoindre maintenant
l'institut qu'après un peu de publicité
pour rejoindre le stade marcel saupin
empois lieu ce soir
baseball nantes valence